hello everyone and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong Mr Mark Ellis sir good
to see you oh good to see you Jacqueline
this is the time of the year that we
love I'm not sure about our fans though
because training camp is now in full
swing your your boy Aaron Rodgers
walking into Camp looking like Cameron
Poe from Conair it's just such a good
time to be a sports fan when you just
have that excitement about the season
and look you could kind of put your
excitement about maybe maybe your team
won the Super Bowl last year and so now
you think you're going to win the Super
Bowl again that was maybe sort of how
this fan base was feeling when this new
Trilogy we're about to talk about was on
on the precipice of being released yeah
and by the end of it they felt like I
did as a Packers fan at the end of our
season
[Music]
that ladies and gentlemen is how you is
how you bring out a film first of all
that's right we're taking a journey that
is The Hobbit trilogy starting with an
Unexpected Journey shout out to our fans
Alex uh Heller from Down Under helier
from Down Under Phil Calderon Anthony
Post Johann Gustafson Gustafson Jimmy
Phillips Santiago Ortiz from Mexico all
around the globe people have been asking
for us to do The Hobbit trilogy we're
finally taking a crack at it this is
definitely one that had a lot of um
let's just say conversation but for as
bad as I think some of us remember this
Trilogy it doesn't actually bear that
out I think with the scores because the
first one Unexpected Journey came out in
2012 64 fresh on Tomato Meter 83 on the
audience score desolation of smog with
74 certified fresh on the Tomato Meter
with an 85 audience score but then the
Battle of Five Armies it really fell off
the cliff at 59 rotten but still a 74
audience score so we have a guess with
us you know this morning that can maybe
help us break it down Mr lawn Harris
he's called the professor I don't even
know Lon where where aren't you writing
these days because I feel like you're a
little bit of everywhere I Scream
Junkies and everyone between I do some
stuff uh there's some stuff for Fred
though I read some stuff for dada write
a news
link TV for inside you know uh some more
news the YouTube channel some more news
you know some odds it ends here and then
uh Mark what about you was this what
what did when did you see this had to be
when you were still in your smo's days
right during the holidays oh yeah we
were in the throes of schmoes and so
there was obviously the big frame rate
debate controversy that we'll get into
when we talk about the movie talk of all
three of these movies but yeah I mean
look I was excited because these are Big
Time spectacle Blockbuster World
establishing movies and the fact that
they were prequels I thought it was
going to be neat to see the ramp up to
the Lord of the Rings Journeys even
though I was never as invested in Lord
of the Rings as some other properties
that that I I love and cherish I
appreciate the Lord of the Rings and so
going into this I was like this is going
to be fun I'm not sure what I'm getting
I'm not sure I'm gonna care as much of
Lord of the Rings and it seems like the
Tomato Meter is born that out because
the three original Lord of the Rings
movies averaged 93 on the Tomato Meter
they're getting into an Ivy League
school uh The Hobbit prequels are
looking at safety Schools they're
looking definitely looking at safety
schools it's a state school very close
to home very close to home but first
Mark real quick let's go ahead and break
down what exactly happens in these three
movies and I don't know good luck could
you say real quick I mean you know what
actually I actually think you can do it
really quickly if you only stay to the
parts that you should have talked about
and not the Ridiculousness that they
added into it all right well look these
are based on appendices and other works
from J.R Tolkien uh and so what we're
doing here is we're basically very
Loosely based I should say so we have
this Hobbit Bilbo and we have a bunch of
orgs so we have a bunch of dwarves and
we have a bunch of elves and we're all
trying to basically battle for survival
and so our Unexpected Journey is going
to take us to places uh like I was
searching for treasure that is guarded
by a dragon named Smaug and then It
ultimately is going to lead up to this
gigantic climactic battle that takes
like nine years to finish and it
involves Sauron who is sending armies Of
Orcs to attack the Lonely Mountain and
so now the fate of Middle Earth is kind
of at stake here and the the the the the
men the humans I guess you should say
the elves the dwarves they're all sort
of in this battle together and either
they're going to team up and they're
going to Prevail or they're going to
continue to fight separately and they're
all likely going to die and Middle Earth
is going to be vanquished forever for
all of times and will never get the
really cool movies that Peter Jackson
gave us in the early 2000s no oh man
that is an indictment I don't I don't
know there's spiders did I point out
their spiders because they're spiders
I don't know if that is an indictment of
how bad they are but it's pretty close I
have a feeling this is where we're gonna
get spicy Mark talking about these
movies so I'm very I'm very excited for
it real quick though Lon is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong with this average
I mean I feel like I feel like it is
justifiable to say that the Hobbit
movies are not on the level of the
original Lord of the Rings trilogy to me
that's fair if I I I can see the Ivy
League school versus maybe a backup
school but I think we're definitely
talking about
ucsystem.cal State system here like I
think we're we're still so so I I feel
like 70s maybe low 80 like that that
that makes a lot of sense to me I think
the audience score on these is pretty
much right on I feel like the critics by
the time you get to Five Armies that's
59 as well come on as the professor is
his name uh on the schmodown I think
it's great that you just shaded an
entire like sub degree um
I got a ton of love for you guys you're
doing great Cal State Sanford a fine
program a fine program everyone's a
matriculation choice I can't say
anything Mark went awake so and he keeps
the he keeps the you know Forest but
it's not really what you do in college
it's not where you go to college it's
what you do once you get there and so
once I got to wake I basically decided
that I didn't really need to go to
college anymore and so if you go to like
a Cal State Fullerton or Cal State
Northridge if you make if you commit to
your classes then you can have a out of
success so I feel like these movies
Jacqueline are more like me getting into
Wake Forest where you're just granted
this prestigious Sheen and veneer but
what did you actually do
what did you add what did I add to the
legacy of Wake Forest that's the same
question I'm going to be asking The
Hobbit prequels about Lord of the Rings
overall because I feel like rotten
tomatoes is right and I feel like the
Battle of the Five Armies might be a
little high for me I just feel like it
just got so long in the tooth but also
say this if these were the movies that
kicked off The Lord of the Rings films
that we got I think we would have looked
at them in a different light because
they are still these amazing
accomplishments of of just cinematic
scope and so to see that on a big screen
if we did not have those other great
older brothers and sisters to compare it
to I think maybe we'd look at The Hobbit
more fondly I think that's really true I
think if you look if you look at these
three movies together we become like I I
was talking uh over the weekend about
Netflix's The Gray Man a very high
profile big budget recent release and
and things that I would point out that
were you know things that I thought made
it not quite as good or that I didn't
enjoy people are so willing to dismiss
they're like yeah okay there's a lot of
Digital Smoke and that scene looks
choppy and blurry and you can't tell
who's Punchy goo but it was fun I liked
it and it's so weird to me that we're
willing to be really forgiving with
something kind of stupid and generic
like the gray man but then something
like this with the this level of detail
and these costumes and these sets and
this massive cast and this really sort
of interesting because he is like what
Mark was saying up top is right that he
is adding a lot he's layering in a lot
of stuff that's not in The Hobbit books
in a really interesting way that kind of
shifts and alters and refracts your view
of everything that happens in The Lord
of the Rings movies and sure it's not
it's not perfect I I grant that there
are there are flaws and nitpicks of
things you can point out but the fact
that we're so harsh on these movies is
so judgmental and then something you
know like morbius will come out and
people be like ah it's morbid time let's
have fun and I just like I don't get the
disconnect there I I don't disagree with
you on that one Lon I think okay
do I have to be this person am I going
to be The Hobbit apologist on this
podcast I guess you know what join us
here we go this over here it's gonna be
me as they like to say uh I think if we
just like take it out of it
64.74 59
the original Lord of the Rings before we
got to see them the folks at new line
were hoping for that kind of critical
reception because they were positive
that that thing was going to fall off a
cliff and if it wasn't stacking up to
the legacy of this incredible Trilogy
that made billions at the box office
swept the Oscars for The Last film and
just became this huge phenomenon to the
point that Amazon literally wrote a
blank check at the hopes of even getting
an inch of that level of cred I don't
think we can say that this is a complete
failure because they managed to do it
the problem with it and the reason why
that score is the way that it is is
because I'm like honestly I'm okay with
it they had to replace the director last
minute Gamo Del Toro was supposed to
make this movie and he basically said f
off I want to go to another Hellboy you
know and there's been so many different
examples of like things that happened in
this movie that should have gone
horribly the fact that they wouldn't
green light it unless they turn turned
it into a three-parter originally they
only wanted to make it a two-parter
there's just so many things that this
Trilogy I think had to overcome and I
think look you guys put Richard Armitage
in a movie and Martin Freeman and
there's just something in the Tumblr
verse of me that says that we have to
give this movie more grace because it
really embraced thirst in a way that I
don't think the first one did outside of
Aragon pushing that door open whoo okay
so I think Rotten Tomatoes is slightly
wrong I think this movie is stacking up
against the legacy of greatness and that
if it wasn't the movie that followed
that with the same principle people in
fact having Peter Jackson involved and
it actually made the reception of it
more harsh
I think that that's it but that's me so
I'm saying Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I
think we can raise this tide a lot
higher yeah I have a counter to that but
less lawn trash The Gray Man again and
just note it took him seven minutes to
bring up the gray man in a hobbit
discussion I'm a little obsessed
for movie talk we can hear from the
critics at the time and then we can get
into our discussion because I have a
counter to Jacqueline's argument okay I
appreciate that and we will definitely
be tuned in for that one but first let's
go ahead and cut this tension and and
take a little a little side trip with Mr
Tim Ryan for our favorite segment two
minutes with Tim Brian cue the music
with him Tim Peter Jackson's Lord of the
Rings trilogy was justifiably celebrated
for among other things brilliantly
adapting three dense Rich volumes into
three dense Rich movies one of the
biggest criticisms of Jackson's Hobbit
trilogy was that it was an adaptation of
a relatively slim book into three epic
movies
so while each entry in The Lord of the
Rings films was certified fresh at least
91 percent on the Tomato Meter The
Hobbit movies were met with a decidedly
more muted reaction
visually stunning in spots action-packed
in others but less magical overall than
the original trilogy and often too
overstretched here's a quick breakdown
The Hobbit and Unexpected Journey from
2012 is fresh at 64 on the Tomato Meter
with 305 reviews and it has an 83
audience score the Desolation of Smaug
from 2013 is certified fresh at 74 with
251 reviews and it has an 85 audience
score
and the Battle of the Five Armies from
2014 is rotten at 59 with 267 reviews
and it has a 74 audience score
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review for The Desolation of Smaug
Sheila O'Malley of Roger ebert.com wrote
the Thematic elements are in place the
emotional tension is highly strung and
the action unfolds in a wave like the
fire erupting from the dragon's mouth
overtaking all in its path
however in a rotten review of the Battle
of the Five Armies Joe gross of the
Austin American statesman wrote to put
it as politely as possible there simply
isn't enough good material there to
sustain three good features so that's
the Hobbit trilogy Jacqueline Mark if
you want to enjoy a film about a Magical
Mystery Tour directed by Peter Jackson
featuring four guys who tried to make
their own Lord of the Rings movie you
should definitely check out get back
starring The Beatles back to you folks
nicely done Tim very nicely done which
get back is pretty great oh I definitely
recommend what you watch Paul McCartney
write the song get back right there it
is unbelievable it is kind of crazy it
is kind of crazy anyway another great
thing that Peter Jackson did an archival
project at that um one of many cool
things that he did
that's look
we're gonna talk about it the critics
had a lot to say at the time but I
really want to not keep folks waiting
any longer for Mark coming through with
the heat so we're gonna go and
transition over into movie talk so he
can bring bring this fire rebuttal Brian
cue the music
[Music]
okay we're gonna set the stage for movie
talk but first Mark what do you got
because like again I'm here with baited
breath okay well I I wanna I wanna get
Jimmy Phillips's email out of the way
because Jimmy Jimmy Phillips is a big
fan he's a fresh member of the ketchup
crew and so Jimmy's gonna set the tone
here for this conversation we're not
going to read the whole email because
Jimmy goes really in depth I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna say at the end
Jimmy says I'll just add the complaints
I've heard about the quote Heirs of the
movie by and large come from people who
have no deep understanding of the
universe and fail to see the forest for
the trees but I'll admit some of the CGI
is bad and they maybe maybe could have
been two movies so we'll talk about all
of these things my counter to the point
that I actually laid out too Jacqueline
lawn is is that you know if we were
comparing The Hobbit prequels to Lord of
the Rings that we would have looked at
them much more favorably however I think
a large part of the appeal of the
prequel trilogy is seeing characters
that we either saw in
the Lord of the Rings trilogy and fell
in love with like a Gandalf or somebody
like that but then you also have the
hints of what's to come with somebody
like Bilbo or the rest of the dwarves
and so without our emotional attachment
to those characters that was built in
from the three great movies we got
there's a chance that we like The Hobbit
movies even less so as much as they had
to follow a tough act they also got a
break from that tough act but I mean of
course though that it wouldn't make
sense to do it any other way because
it's a continuation of a franchise that
in a lot of ways this is what makes The
Hobbit movies so worthwhile like worth
making like a lot of people were like
why do we need this it's not as
important a story you know like and and
I think there are a lot of instances
like uh you know when we see Lego loss
and we start to understand his conflict
with the dwarves which then in The Lord
of the Rings movies when he befriends
Gimli it enhances our understanding of
the importance of that relationship to
him because it's how he's gotten over
this you know like this mentioned he
used to have that we see in The Hobbit
so I mean I don't think that's a
criticism so much I think that's like
some of the best stuff I think Jackson
does in The Hobbit movies is how he or
uh saruman's like initial moment of
betrayal when he first sees the Power of
Sauron and he's like oh I want to tap
some of this for myself I'll tell them
don't worry about Sarah let me worry
about Sarah like like I I love those
kinds of moments and I don't think
that's a knock on oh well we wouldn't
enjoy this movie unless we had those
other movies it's like he's doing all of
this cool work threading these two
trilogies together even though when
Tolkien wrote The Hobbit he didn't even
know there was going to be a Lord of the
Rings yeah and I was just gonna add this
too like I get what you're saying Mark
but I just think any good will that the
series got with familiarity was quickly
dissipated by the armchair critics who
felt some kind of way about the first
Trilogy I just feel like again like it
just overweighted it's the same thing
that's gonna happen with Avatar when it
comes out later this this is not a movie
that you can even say to some people oh
you haven't seen it the box office says
different everybody saw this movie and
if they didn't see it it permeated the
culture so much that it was like
impossible to ignore you could have
voided Game of Thrones for the entire
run that it was on television you would
have known that was a thing there was no
way you were not getting involved in The
Lord of the Rings so there were plenty
of people who went to go see The Hobbit
who hadn't seen the Lord of the Rings in
theaters who hadn't really had that
Affinity towards it it was just
something that maybe one of those people
brought them to and even those people I
think would say that it was still a good
incredible fun adventure
I just again that's why I go to this
audience score like look at the audience
score it's not even close it's 83 85 and
80 and 74. I have to think that is not
just Lord of the Rings heads I think
it's because it was fun to watch to to
both y'all's point my favorite movie of
the three is the is an Unexpected
Journey because I I love the way that
it's set up what we're going to
hopefully accomplish in this Trilogy
gave us some of that familiarity it
introduced some of the characters that
we had known and loved already but it
also felt like more of an origin story
than we ever got before you know you
know it was like we got to be
reintroduced to some of these characters
and we got new ones that we saw were
laying the groundwork for what was to
come in the next five movies so to see
that I thought was really cool the the
issue that I always have with people is
and I get that you know we all become
this person from time to time where you
say well you don't have a deep
understanding of the war therefore
that's why you don't like the movie and
I'm going like well it's not necessarily
my job to have to do hours and hours of
research to it just so that I can
appreciate a movie I look at it as the
movie's job sometimes the movie doesn't
have to hold my hand but I'm not going
to necessarily blame me for not putting
in the research and that's why I didn't
enjoy the movie
anything against it Lon for you just
like listening to what Jimmy had to say
about it do you think like like do you
think it was Miss it was like
misunderstanding because I think you
kind of maybe you could at least think
of the way the critics saw it at the
time even if you don't necessarily agree
with it yeah I mean I think there's
definitely the Temptation because it is
it exactly like what what some of the
critics were saying it's it's this it's
a smaller book it's a smaller original
work so Jackson's adding a lot more of
his own ideas to really expand it and I
think that that's the sort of thing even
when you just lay it out in words
without watching three movies it sounds
like a little bit of ego there I know
I'm not accusing Peter Jackson of
anything but I think it's really easy to
knock a project like that a guy's gonna
come along and be like oh this Jr token
book's not that long well let me put a
lot of my own ideas into it and I think
that's a really easy thing to sort of go
at him for and I think a lot of people
did that when actually I think a lot of
the stuff that he adds I mean you know
may not be like super crucial like oh he
gave the Orcs more of a developed story
and a reason for wanting to get Thor and
Oakenshield specifically and like but I
mean I think a lot of I think a lot of
it works and I think there was a lot of
cynicism around that I also think we we
kind of you can't really talk about the
reaction too much more without talking
about the visuals the frame rate stuff
which I think really turned off a lot of
people and does give the movie a very
different and somewhat Unique Look I
think it works I think it lends it kind
of a
storybook quality and sort of sets it
apart from The Lord of the Rings movies
like it looks visually distinctive like
its own thing while still being set in
Middle Earth but I also get it's a very
like hyper real
stylized sort of look and I think that
turned a lot of people off like right
away yeah I will say this
um first of all we are going to talk
about the CGI and the more specifics of
the film but I want to kind of keep it
on the the overview of all three but in
general I will say Peter Jackson made a
lot of stylistic choices with the first
three Lord of the Rings the only
difference is with that one is they were
very specific like the look of
Fellowship of the Ring is very different
than the look of two towers as far as
the cinematography and the lighting a
lot of it thematically but some of it
literally how they chose to shoot these
things because they changed the way they
shot after they wrapped the first one
because remember they kind of shot it
all in big chunks yeah so I think with
this particular one especially with the
The Hobbit franchise maybe it was the
frame rate but I also think it was the
fact that so many people went into this
one with should this exist should this
exist it's the very thing that they did
with West Side Story the difference is
when Steven Spielberg made West Side
Story and then they finally got to see
it everyone was like oh yeah I can see
you know you did some things with that
he added things too he changed things
from the original he changed aspects of
Bernstein's score like that is like
sacrilegious in a lot of cases for a lot
of musical theater people but he made
all of those grand sweeping changes and
all the people came for the movie and
for a lot of different things what
Steven Spielberg wasn't one of them and
I think that's the different Peter
Jackson didn't get that time to do it
like that that's a that's a very fair
point because you look at this and it's
hard to not compare this the original
trilogy the classic Trilogy and the
prequels to the other classic Trilogy in
the prequels from Star Wars right the
difference being that there were a lot
of folks like Jacqueline was saying
saying do we really need another three
Lord of the Rings movies do we need
three Hobbit movies whereas when George
Lucas announced that he's going back and
making the prequels for Star Wars we
were all like finally we've been waiting
for this forever like the opposite yeah
but Peter Jackson does a much better job
than my Boy George Lucas of marrying the
mythology to the original without there
being a lot of like well but wait if
that happened there then how does this
happen there you know there was no like
you know Darth Vader as a kid built
C-3PO kind of stuff where you're like
huh there wasn't a lot of midi Glory
it's like what those were never what so
I mean I felt I think it's like the
Treatise is this idea it's like look
you're giving a fascist and fascism An
Origin story this is probably not the
same as you know defeating the evil
empire over the course of three movies
like do you see what I mean like that's
literally why as I go back on the
prequels now I'm like the the conceit of
those movies to dictate the origin of
the Empire you're essentially asking
someone to retrace the origin of Nazism
and like I don't know if that's like a
fun ride for a lot of people do you feel
me and then Darth Vader being the
ultimate fascist so like there's pod
racing too
also Padres let's look at these three
films individually I think I've talked a
little bit about out how I feel about
the response to each one of them but
let's go ahead and at least start to
like rank them Mark I'm gonna hold off
on you because I'm I'm gonna see what
Lon has to say because I think most
people operate with a very similar
ranking with just these three but Lana
I'll ask you yeah I heard I heard Mark
offering the the first one I feel like
the first two for me are are pretty much
on an even Keel I I'm probably tempted
to go Desolation of Smaug is my top one
I really like uh Benedict cumberbatch's
take on The Voice I really like those
interactions between him and Bilbo uh I
I just I feel like that one kind of
moves the best uh and has that has the
best sort of cutting back and forth
between all of the different sort of
story lines the Gandalf storyline where
he's a you know sort of investigating
The Necromancer versus the sort of main
Journey uh I do feel like I like I like
battle with the Five Armies a lot I feel
like action wise it's probably the
biggest it's the one that's the most
epic and the most satisfying in that way
and I really like the sort of the the
conflict around Thor and Oakenshield and
how there's like a depth to that and to
where he sort of ends up there's a
complexity to his storyline that I think
maybe is kind of not in Lord of the
Rings which is more of a kind of good
conventional good versus evil sacrifice
Duty kind of story I think he I like how
Jackson sort of teases out the
complexity at the end of uh of Five
Armies I do agree it gets it gets the
first hour of Five Armies takes a little
bit to get going I feel like that's
probably the weakest stretch in the
whole trilogy I'm not crazy about Alfred
of Lake town we spend a lot of time with
that guy it's a little bogged down in
that first hour I think once the action
once we're at Erebor and the the Five
Armies are collecting I feel like things
pick up but that one is a little bit
slower so I would say that's that's in
my third place spot Mark where you got I
think that I have I have unexpected
Journey and then I have desolation of
smile but desolation system I will say
has my what my favorite sequence in the
prequel trilogy is what llama was saying
where we're in Scrooge mcduck's Vault
and we wake up Smaug and we just get to
have a really cool cat and mouse sort of
conversation and I thought that was
awesome then you also see the full might
have smog that continues into very
briefly into the Battle of the Five
Armies and then the battle of the farmer
armies I just feel like falls off a
cliff not not plummets to its death but
just is clearly an inferior movie to the
first two particularly given that that
was the one that we were hoping was
going to just be this this great
crowning achievement like what Return of
the King was and so I just felt like it
got so long in the tooth even by the
time we get to the battles it felt a
little wearying and I sort of thought
the CGI was the weakest or maybe Peter
Jackson asked the most of the CGI in
Battle of the Five Armies and I don't
think that it holds up as well as is in
the first two I think he asked for more
for women and I think um well we know
that he had significantly less time so
the whole thing was just rush I mean say
what you want to about you know the Lord
of the Rings it was a big bet but it was
a big bet that they gave them a ton of
time to do I mean they filmed that first
section over what 10 months almost
almost 14 total with all of the like
total time in New Zealand so I'm like
yeah they yeah very much a different
vibe than an Unexpected Journey because
like look Martin Freeman was down there
for forever it seems like based on you
know the behind the scenes stuff because
if you haven't seen those DVDs where
they talk about it yeah he was down
there for forever but I don't know if
that was the case with a lot of the
miniature stuff because that's all the
stuff that Guillermo was doing before he
kind of basically said I'm not a part of
this so like all that pre-production
stuff that like Jackson and Philippa and
all the people involved with Lord of the
Rings spent months almost years doing
he had to like Fast Track all that stuff
and so I I'm not surprised that certain
things feel a little like rushed um I'm
with you Mark I go one two three uh I
really like desolation of smoke I like
that it did Cumberbatch performance it's
incredible but I just really love
starting it off in hobbiton I love Bilbo
being the sort of odd man out and really
sort of just waking up one day like
like not waking up one day I should say
very reluctantly deciding that he needs
to like get his stuff together and maybe
take this adventure so yeah I really
enjoyed an expected journey and I just I
love Martin Freeman's performance I
don't think we talk about it enough
we will go ahead and talk about favorite
scenes
um I'll start with you on this one mark
do you have one I guess you've already
sort of like teased it out but talk
about maybe your favorite scene is it
the smog one that you started said this
fat one's way up there too but I'm gonna
defend my favorite movie here because
Unexpected Journey is has so much that I
love in movies not the least of which is
like a rousing sort of pregame locker
room talk but this is like a song that
they're all singing and and it's it's
the night before where we're actually
gonna go out on a quest and to see all
of these these dwarves just like like
kind of cranking out this weird tune
it's awesome and it kind of pumps me up
Glory
Glory come on
the winds were moaning
in the night
[Music]
I like that and then I also like
radagast the brown get just coming out
of nowhere like Wilford Brimley in the
Ewoks movies just this weirdo that kind
of lives in the woods I like finding the
the hidden passage to rivendale and I
love the stone giants there's just
there's so many cool creatures that we
get to see in the in an Unexpected
Journey and it's also nice to get to
know Bilbo because I I feel like we I
never really got to know who Bilbo was
and through the first three classic
Trilogy movies he was always that guy
that freaked out when he saw the ring
and I could never get that out of my
head so to get a new perspective on
Bilbo being an actual
human Hobbit versus an actual being that
you care about I thought was what was
well done and and I was invested in his
journey I dig that
favorites uh scene from the trilogy in
general uh well I do want to point out
we uh Mark was talking about Unexpected
Journey my favorite sequence is
unexpected Journey is one of I think the
highlights of the whole trilogy and
that's the escape from Goblin Town which
is just such a it's such a vintage Peter
jacksony kind of sequence like he really
gets into the the sort of monstersm and
grotesqueness Of the Goblins uh and it
gives it that kind of like throwback
sort of fun like almost an 80s Adventure
movie sort of vibe to that sequence I
really love it it feels almost like
something out of a classic Peter Jackson
horror film but updated in this Middle
Earth world you thought you could Escape
me
what are you going to do now is it
that'll do it
[Music]
the other thing I'd like to highlight
just as I'm going to talk about favorite
stuff Lee Pace's performance as
trendwheel is so good in these movies he
Nails the like
cold imperiousness of the elves better
than anyone else in any of these movies
I think there's there's a scene in five
armies where he shows up and the humans
from Lake Town think that he's there to
help them because they bring food he's
riding like a moose or like a deer with
these huge moose antlers and and he's
like no I'm here for these diamonds
they'll have gems and he he owes me my
diamonds and it's just it's like the
perfect casting of Lee Pace and it's
just say it's so delivered so well from
the top of this ridiculous beast and I I
really love that I do love these sort of
like very it's it's it's kind of Snow
White it's kind of Three Stooges with
the dwarfs they very much have a lot of
comedic moments as they did in the first
one with the some of the hobbits
um but I would actually say the fish
falling in love with the bird scenario
which is the elf falling in love with
the dwarf uh through the course of this
movies yes I'm gonna give thirst its
moment in the sun here because it's so
good it's so cute well first of all
um the actor who plays uh Keely is
um uh also incredibly cute and hilarious
and so like I don't know I'm just like I
I loved that whole thing I loved what
Evangeline Lilly did with it it's it's
it was cute I was digging it I I think
it sets the foundation for Gimli and
like a list later in a more romance type
setting although there's plenty of fan
fiction that tries to speak to the to
the romance between them
um I love that because even in The Lord
of the Rings one of my favorite things
is from the extended edition when you
find out boromir's uh brother marries
the girl that's like I am no man uh
airmir like like that's like one of my
favorite things it's like the little
side romances that you find out happen
uh through the course of The Lord of the
Rings like there are other people that
fall in love in this story besides you
know Sam Rosie cotton and Aragon
sick uh what about you mark like we've
already gone through favorite scenes is
there a favorite character that you love
I think I've also talked about favorite
characters or is there one particular uh
character moment that you really want to
like outshine well I I agree with Juan
that I think that Thorin Oakenshield
sort of uh Arc is very uh different and
and fresh that as opposed to what we
would have seen in the original trilogy
and and a lot of that is thanks to
Richard Armitage because I just think
he's brilliant throughout these movies
and you but I'm also going to say that
Andy Circus is Gollum leaves I mean he's
so good when he's on screen it was so
great to see him but the cool behind the
scenes fact is that Andy Circus shot his
scenes as Gollum in like a week for at
least for one of the movies and then he
stayed on to be like the second A.D yeah
and sort of get his directing chops and
that's why now you see him directing
movies and it's like so he's sort of
learning at the foot of Peter Jackson
for these movies but if I had to pick
one and I don't want to take Juan's a
certain famous voice actor that's
voicing a giant dragon I would go with
Richard Armitage as Thorin Oak and
shield but also give many props to
Martin Freeman simply because he wasn't
cast as Bilbo until like six weeks
before production began so I mean you
talk about like coming in the last week
of training camp and having to learn the
whole Playbook that's a real impressive
performance to pull off yeah and very
very at least he started with the right
character this time the last time he
started with the wrong actor and had to
recast it so at least he got that one uh
I think he stresses over his lead actors
just based on that you know he stresses
over it maybe overthinks it because I'm
gonna go ahead and say Martin Freeman is
my favorite Choice Everett Ross uh
whether he's playing Dr John Watson uh
whether he's in this as Bilbo it don't
matter I just love him I do he's
absolutely hilarious he gives off very
like I'm just over it British dry humor
and if you watch the Lord of the Rings
behind the scenes he flips off every
single camera that comes within 10 feet
of him for the behind the scenes footage
because apparently so like when you're
in The Lord of the Rings movies they
have to like film them all the time for
their BTS stuff and they know they're
overshooting all this stuff and
apparently Martin Freeman didn't like
that and so he knew the best way to get
them to stop filming him was to flip
them off and so he literally like they
did a montage Supercut and him just
flipping off everyone so great but he
also the character of Bilbo reminds me a
lot of me where he's just kind of happy
being being who he is and he doesn't
really want to go on an adventure it's
like I don't really want a lot of
hurdles or challenges in my life and you
get thrown something you're like fine
I'll go you end up being richer for the
journey but you never really want to go
you know you just kind of want to hang
out relax with your dog yeah he's like
he's got like 10 Tim from the office
still in this photography you feel like
he's gonna just like break the fourth
wall and be like oh yeah also I want to
let people know one of the reasons why
we love uh Thorin Oakenshield so much is
because Richard Armitage is one of the
most talented voice actors to ever grace
the planet he voices Castlevania which
uh a lot of folks known for I know him
from voicing romance novels
that Wolverine podcast yeah he also does
the Wolverine podcast like this guy good
Wolverine this guy's voice like like so
a lot of people talk about like Morgan
Freeman and His Voice work in certain
circles Richard Armitage is like girl
him and Sebastian you are so Richard I'm
saying I should take that back has only
done one full romance novel but he does
a lot of romantic British things so he
does like Romeo and Juliet and
Shakespeare and that kind of stuff so
you can definitely hear him Romancing
you even if it isn't you know
Shakespearean he was also uh Francis
Dollarhide in uh Hannibal yes he was a
red dragon when they did their Red
Dragon season oh my God yeah he was no
he's great and yeah his voice is
seductive I will just say it like you
there's a reason why everyone listens to
Thor and Oak and shield and the thing
it's that Timber and it's just like it
just makes you stand at attention trust
me it makes it scary yeah that third
movie when he does he he manages that
transition really well it could have
been cheesy but it does it so well and
yeah that's the voice acting um yeah for
the ladies gays and days listening
please do yourself a favor and go listen
to Mr Richard Armitage he is he's quite
seductive that's not the only seductive
thing though there's lots of things that
were are auditorily pleasing in The
Hobbit including the score which was
very moving and sweeping and one that is
actually a frequent rotation on my
instrumental playlist that I use to try
to write things so I dug the music uh
that's Newman right yeah it's gotta be
right yeah uh what about you mark oh no
Howard Shore sure sure that's right no
that is Howard Shore you're right that
is Howard Shore what about you mark uh
did you have any particular what would
you say is the most attractive aspect to
the film series is it the music of the
plot I think we can both say it's not
the CGI outside of the acting and maybe
the direction yeah it's not the 48
frames sorry Juan I can't I can't get
past it I I it doesn't like completely
ruin the movie for me but I do feel like
I'm front row at a Broadway production
and that's on a good day with being the
48 frames a bad day is like it looks
like the end of peewee's big adventure
when he's just riding through movie sets
and it it just everything felt more
artificial to me than than I it should
have because it's like you're working
that hard to make all the stuff look
real why would you it's almost like it
does a disservice to everybody's hard
work that you're filming in 48 frames
um but having said that I still think
the music's great I think most of the
CGI holds up really well but it's the
interaction of the characters for me
it's the team up aspect of these movies
that I really buy into so and that's why
I think Thorin oakenshield's plotline is
so interesting is because you don't know
which way this guy is going to break
because he's got his own motivations
he's also thinking about the bigger
scope and the when when you have a bunch
of different I mean you're talking about
a bunch of different real species here
teaming up to all figure out are we
going to be a team here are we going to
be divided amongst ourselves it's a
really cool through line and it's a
really interesting thing and I just wish
that it played out in a more exciting
fashion and that's weird to say given
that the Battle of the Five Armies is
pretty much a giant battle the last hour
and a half it just never felt that
moving to me by the time we got there I
don't think it's uh I don't think
there's many people that disagree with
you on that particular aspect I still
can't put my finger on why it other than
maybe you know you could have truncated
it into two movies like what Peter
originally wanted to do but it's just
like we've been waiting for this battle
for this epic epic Climax and by the
time we get there it just feels like
well okay we're here we saw Grandma uh
what time we leaving what time are we
going back home hey uh yeah I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna say that that's
completely yeah it's it's very pervasive
opinion I'll put it to you that way but
I think more people complain about the
pacing in general across the three films
like basically the idea that you could
Topher Grace this and make a good clean
movie and that there was a certain level
of greed I think surrounding the
promotion of this movie that people felt
like people just felt it felt greedy for
them to do it the way that they were
doing it the fact that they were doing
it so quickly the fact that they were
doing it in a three-parter like
everything just reeked of We Are Gonna
bleed this dry and I think like people
it's almost like you every every studio
is needy for box office receipts but
when you look needy it's almost worse
does that make sense I I don't know I
think that for me was the biggest thing
that people railed against that was the
thing that that damaged it is that they
they went into this thing thinking it
was bad and that the people involved in
it were doing it for poor reasons and
anything about it that was anything less
than Stellar they were gonna rip I don't
know lawn what about you what do you
think was the most glaring thing sort of
stood out from you from all the three
films good or bad uh yeah I mean I think
I think you're I think this is basically
correct I think people went in with a
pretty cynical mindset with a pretty
demanding mindset I mean to me I think
that the the frame rate conversation as
I recall when these movies came out
dominated certainly the first movie that
was what people were talking about it
that was like when people would go see
it how did you think it looked what did
you think and everybody had their take
and it became the kind of this the
Battle of the Five hot takes or whatever
and I I think that's so overshadowed the
content that for almost like a year
afterwards I would try to talk about the
movies and people would just want to
talk about why does it look so shiny or
why does it look like like why you know
why does it look like so photo realistic
but hyper real or why the colors all
weirded and I I just feel like it
couldn't it couldn't really shake that
for a really long time I agree too with
what you're saying Jacqueline that the
the conversation about should this have
been one movie should this have been two
movies why does it need to be three
buters and I I always kind of feel like
that's a silly like well why why make
movies just go go build a bridge if you
want to be super productive like no you
don't need any movie right like I I
always feel like that's kind of a silly
conversation it got really over the top
with this one like like no we don't need
more Middle Earth boobies we we want
them it's fun to spend time in Middle
Earth and I agree that that is actually
like not a poor sentiment I think if it
didn't look so transparent in their
efforts that I I don't think it was that
I I agree with you that is a Like Straw
argument and I think sometimes it's just
argument for a movie that may doesn't
speak to whichever audience member there
was but this one was so pervasive and I
think so many people were kind of like
okay you know what I mean like this was
I think a little bit of that and
honestly it's something that Harry
Potter dealt with when they did the
cursed child too it's it's sort of like
people had already paid out the nose and
given so much to these characters in
this world they felt like if you're
coming back at least make me feel that
it's going to be worth my time I hope
they're feeling that about the Amazon
show
um they had their panel at Comic-Con not
too long ago Stephen Colbert I think
they can't keep him away from there
um no I don't even think they pay them
or put them up in a hotel room I mean I
think Stephen Colbert's like look you're
not going to stop me from getting into
the room
would elf Garb like ready to go I worry
for this show if I'm being really honest
not because I think it'll be bad but
just because
I don't think it's going to be what
people expect like they're going way far
back like way far back and then intend
to eventually get to where the events of
the Lord of the Rings end like that's
the that's the goal yeah I I I mean it's
like I feel like it's a plus and a minus
like on the good of the good side they
don't have to deal with anything they
don't want to it's it's thousands of
years before they can pick and choose
the elements that they like they can
make up their own stuff it's a lot of
freedom you wouldn't have if you were
doing like Obi-Wan you know where like
this has to fit right into the middle of
an ongoing story but there's so few
elements that people will really
recognize they're they're branching out
into this whole new part of the world
like there are different continents in
Middle Earth at this point that don't
exist in Lord of the Rings so I feel
like it's going to feel really far into
people too and they're gonna have their
work cut out for them to make it feel
sufficiently lord of the ringsy you know
that's why I'm so fascinated by it
though because again I mean this is
something that you know Star Wars hasn't
been able to do it hasn't been able to
get out of its own sandbox and now Lord
of the Rings like okay we're going back
thousands of years and we're going to
tell you a story and I hope that I hope
people support at least I hope people
give it a chance I think they will it's
going to get a lot of promotion I'm
gonna give it a shot I'm excited for it
I'm excited that I don't know a lot of
the characters or at least I don't think
I do there's going to be ties obviously
with people with folks like Sauron and
stuff like that but I'm excited for what
this could bring yeah elrond Galadriel
and Sauron I think are the only major
characters that we know Gandalf will
probably show up at some point I've got
it at some point he's alive I'm more
interested in the long game of it I'm
sort of interested this is the way I
feel like when when we first when when
Kevin feige first said I think after
Iron Man 2 that they were plotting a
10-year plan for the MCU that was like
the very first time he mentioned that
and I remember when he mentioned that I
was like
I don't know if I'm buying your level of
crazy but I'm at least gonna like get a
ticket for the show you know what I mean
like I don't know if I'm buying it but
like I'm gonna come take a peek and so
that's the way I feel with the Lord of
the Rings it's like I don't know if this
gamble is gonna pay off y'all paid a lot
of money y'all have a lot of money but
y'all paid a lot of money for this show
I hope it's worth it like I really hope
it's worth it I hope it's worth your
time I hope it's worth your effort
there's another show that's a prequel
that's a high fantasy prequel that is
going through a similar thing and I just
wonder like it seems like every single
like streaming service is trying to find
their Game of Thrones Amazon more than
anyone else and yeah well that Bezos had
that meeting where he apparently like
fist on the desk like get me a game of
thrones so like very explicitly like we
gotta go get Jeff A Game of Thrones
we're gonna go get Jeff and Game of
Thrones so then they made Wheel of Time
and they're like we're gonna go get then
so um like I said and and also that's I
said two there's three there's the
Sandman series two which is a comic but
it's also very high fantasy so it's so
interesting to see what these all these
people are doing they're all chasing the
same Banner it's gonna be interesting to
see who maybe comes out on top but like
I said I bought a ticket to the show
I'm excited
actually
real quick of those three which do y'all
think would have the best chance of
being Lord of the Rings Sandman Lord
Lord of the Rings rings of power or the
Game of Thrones prequel uh House of
dragon ooh
um I still have to go with Lord of the
Rings simply because I think there's
there's a sour taste in a lot of Game of
Thrones fans mouth from the most recent
season yeah and and Sandman I love
personally I just don't think that it's
got the I don't think it's got the scope
of appeal to a mass audience in the same
way that's as accessible as something
like a known property like Lord of the
Rings so I'm I'm still saying it's going
to be the ring of power what about Elon
I'm I'm inclined to agree I feel like
the exactly what we've been talking
about where there was a lot of cynicism
and sort of jaded audience going into
The Hobbit films I feel like you've got
to counteract a lot of that coming out
of Game of Thrones like there's just a
lot of generally negative sentiment
about how that previous Show wrapped up
and the fact that George R Martin hasn't
finished the books and I think a lot of
people feel like they were left hanging
by that franchise and so I feel like a
lot of that's going to get taken out on
the new one
um I've been inclined to go Lord of the
Rings too but I do feel like it really
looks like they're nailing it that
Sandman trailer was really great and it
feels like so much like the world of
those early Sandman comics and I'm very
I've been very like cautious and guarded
because I love those comics and I was
like I don't know if that makes sense as
a Netflix show but I feel like if
they're if they're nailing it the way it
looks like they might be it could be
Sandman is the next big phenomenon yeah
that is actually the one that I was
gonna bet of those three and the main
reason is especially what's interesting
obviously Tolkien cannot be involved but
his family is involved in The Lord of
the Rings show all three of them have
intimate involvement with their creators
I think Neil Gaiman is the only one of
those that having intimate involvement
could be a good thing because all of the
good Neil ad game and adaptations had
him involved early on and all the bad
ones didn't true so that I think is a
good place to end on that one basically
saying we'll see and yay Sandman
it was cool it looks cool like a lot of
those sequences really do look like
they've somehow captured the style and
aesthetic of those books which I didn't
think was possible yeah and look hey
bookmark this page when we're wrong and
House of dragon cleans up the Emmys uh
and he's next year you can you can say
that we were wrong sir thank you so much
for joining us it is always a pleasure
it feels educational
professorial
very kind of yeah always always happy to
be here that's it for us to speak blonde
first of all though real quick uh where
can folks find you what else are you
working on what should they be checking
out just find me on Twitter at l-o-n-s
that's the best place to uh keep up with
everything I'm working on and if you
want to check out my podcast with Hal
redneck it's called binge boys you can
find that on Spotify uh Apple uh podcast
wherever you get your podcasts just want
to let folks remind you you can be like
Jimmy you can recommend a movie to us
just make sure your email us as RT is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com also don't
forget to rate review And subscribe and
share this with all of your friends on
every platform follow if it makes you do
that but we want to tell people about
this podcast so they can tell us all the
ways that we were wrong and we will see
you all next time on Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you